[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
histoire de la coupe du monde de
football la coupe du monde de football
l'autre fait le plus illustre du sport
international
[Musique]
un mois d'une compétition organisée pour
la première fois en 1994 par les états
unis dans 9 des principales villes du
pays
un spectacle captivant relayé par 180
télévision
trois millions de spectateurs pour vivre
sur place la grande fête du football
mondial ce qui se fait de plus
pittoresques en matière de supporters
pour galvaniser ce qui se faisait plus
d'un an d'une aux amateurs de virtuoses
du talent
[Applaudissements]
il semble que l'on jouait déjà au
football en angleterre au 12e siècle
ce qui est sûr c'est que dans ce pays il
ya 150 ans un match entre équipes de
villages voisins constituent est un
véritable événement une confrontation
collective d'ailleurs assez difficile à
suivre
[Musique]
d'état est délicat c'est un art sous
couvert de roses qui servait de but
[Musique]
de la renaissance les italiens pratiquer
un jeu comparable un ballon âprement
disputé par deux équipes de 27 courage
aux jeunes gens en haut de choses
aujourd'hui encore on perpétue la
tradition à fleurance
[Musique]
mais c'est en angleterre encore quand en
1863 réunis dans un pub de liverpool
un groupe de pratiquants enthousiaste
format la football association et jeter
les bases des règles du football moderne
elle fixe l effectif de onze joueurs par
équipe
la taille des buts la durée des matchs
et les prérogatives de larbitre
[Musique]
fulgurant en grande bretagne le succès
du football gagne a très vite le
continent puis l'ensemble du monde
de nouvelles associations furent créés
par centaines y compris d'ailleurs des
ligues féminines
[Musique]
cela n'excluait pas quelques variantes
comme en inde où il était d'usagé de
jouer dienné les français furent à
l'origine de la création en 1904 de la
fédération internationale de football et
d'un projet de coupe du monde
[Musique]
mais la première guerre mondiale ruina
pour longtemps cette ambitieuse
initiative
il fallut ensuite quinze ans à la fifa
pour regrouper ses forces grâce
notamment aux efforts de jules rimet élu
président de l'association en 1921
aujourd'hui la fifa regroupe 174 pays 44
en europe 29 en amérique du nord et
caraïbes 10 en amérique du sud 50 en
afrique 35 en asie 6 en océanie
[Musique]
la première coupe du monde fut organisée
en 1930 en uruguay les équipes
convergèrent du monde entier toute une
expédition à l'époque
[Musique]
la grande aventure débutée le 18 juillet
à montevideo
c'est à l'équipe des états unis que
revint l'honneur de marquer le premier
but dans une coupe du monde
au départ on a nous accordez pas une
chance après notre deuxième match on
nous donnait favoris
[Applaudissements]
il dure cependant s'incliner sous la
pression sud américaine
le meilleur buteur l'argentin stabile la
finale oppose d'argentine à l'uruguay
c'est un joueur manchots castro qui
marque le but décisif faisant de
l'uruguay le premier champion du monde
de football
[Applaudissements]
en 1934 mussolini accueilli
personnellement les 32 délégations qui
allait participer à rome à la deuxième
édition de la coupe
il transforme à l'événement en opération
de relations publiques
d'autant que son pays accède à la finale
le manager italien vittorio pozzo
galvani son équipe est la condition de
la victoire
[Applaudissements]
les italiens sont opposés à la
tchécoslovaquie dont les supporters à
une grande distance à parcourir pour
venir soutenir leur équipe en masse mais
aussi en vain car l'équipe d'italie
remporté par 2 buts à 1
[Applaudissements]
la fifa a exprimé des réserves sur la
récupération de la compétition quand le
pouvoir fasciste
il n'empêche les preuves suscita un
énorme engouement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la coupe du monde 1938 je dispute à à
paris les français investir 2 millions
de francs dans son organisation
du jamais vu à l'époque
[Musique]
autre record celui des but marqué au
premier tour le brésil s'impose de
justesse contre la pologne 6 buts à 5
la finale se dispute entre l'équipe
d'italie toujours pilotée par pozzo et
celle de hongrie
les italiens gained avec mérite par 4
buts à 2 et remporté les trophées pour
la deuxième fois
[Applaudissements]
la compétition était en plein essor mais
cette euphorie se trouva rapidement mis
en veilleuse pendant une décennie le
monde allait se trouver mobilisés par
d'autres préoccupations
[Musique]
ce n'est que 12 ans plus tard en 1950
que loin de l'europe encore en une fête
organisée au brésil
la quatrième édition de la coupe
l'équipe italie héritière du titre
s'échauffant sur le bateau qui l'a
conduit à rio
m
[Musique]
les brésiliens ont aménagé un stade
immense pouvant contenir plus de deux
cent mille personnes et qui demeure l'un
des plus vastes du monde
[Musique]
regrettable péripéties les indiens se
retirèrent de la compétition après que
la fifa ait prétendu leur imposer le
port des chaussures pour la première
fois les anglais accéder à la phase
finale
mais à la stupéfaction générale ils
furent battus 1 à 0 par les états unis
c'est devant une assistance record que
se disputent la finale entre le brésil
et l'uruguay
le brésil est favori il est battu par 2
buts à 1 des supporters pique des crises
d'hystérie
on parle de cas le suicide
une samba avait été dédié à la victoire
brésilienne il n'entendait jamais la
première note un véritable enjeu de
deuil pour le football brésilien
[Musique]
en 1954 la compétition retraverser
l'atlantique
la suisse qui inaugurait ce retour à
l'europe mis les petits plats dans les
grands
elle fit frappé démener pour marquer
l'événement une initiative originale en
matière de marketing
autres nouveautés promises à un bel
avenir
la retransmission télévisée des
compétitions
[Applaudissements]
ce fut aussi la grande année des buteurs
140 buts marqués en 26 matches
[Applaudissements]
par un dimanche pluvieux la star
ambroise puskas mène son équipe à
l'assaut de la finale qui l'opposé à
l'allemagne de l'ouest
malgré une blessure subie quelques jours
plus tôt puskas fait des merveilles
il marque à deux reprises au cours des
huit premières minutes
mais les allemands s'accroche
[Applaudissements]
il marque un premier but
puis une seconde
l'allemagne égalise et un troisième
l'allemagne remporté 3 à 2 mais temps
fou à une exceptionnelle série hongroise
de 30 matchs internationaux sans défaite
[Applaudissements]
à l'occasion de la coupe du monde 1958
disputé en suède
les supporters du monde entier de
découvrir un jeune prodige brésilien
appelé pelé une époustouflante vedette
offensive pour une équipe au mieux de sa
forme
le brésil entre l'usi cette année là un
système de jeu qui allait faire fortune
le 4-2-4 quatre défenseurs deux milieux
de terrain quatre attaquants
[Musique]
jouant sur classement le brésil est
opposée en finale à la suède
c'est goliath contre david et pourtant
c'est david qui ouvre la marque
[Musique]
mais les sud américains prennent
rapidement le dessus pour l'emporter 5 à
[Musique]
en marquant le troisième de ses buts
polesso 10 à 17 ans au rang de héros
national et devient grâce notamment à la
télévision la nouvelle coqueluche du
football mondial
[Applaudissements]
une des vedettes de cette équipe
brésilienne s'appelait mario zagallo il
avait remporté deux autres coupes du
monde en 1962 comme joueur et en 1970
comme manager mai 1958 demeure pour lui
un souvenir exceptionnel descriptible
quand je repense aux gens de la chair de
poule
c'était tellement inattendu personne n'y
croyait
notre retour en suède a soulevé le
brésil d'entousiasme et notre retour au
pays était inoubliable
oui
choisie pour organiser la coupe en 1962
le chili subi au cours des deux années
précédentes des tremblements de terre si
destructeur qui le menaçait de
compromettre la compétition
les chiliens réussir cependant à relever
le défi et le magnifique stade de
santiago fut le théâtre de l'un des
matches les plus disputés de l'histoire
de la coupe il opposa le chili et
l'italie qui l'emporta 2 buts à 0 et il
fut à ce point violent qu'on le baptisa
la bataille de santiago il fallut
beaucoup de diplomatie à l'arbitré
anglais ken ashton pour éviter qu'il se
transforme en pugilat collectif il a été
très difficile de remplir mon rôle
d'arbitré
ce match personne ne semblait souhaiter
qu'il est là tout le monde s'en sort
volontiers passée et notamment le fait
que le public sur le terrain avaient
réservé un très mauvais accueil à
l'équipe italienne
cela couvait d'ailleurs depuis plusieurs
jours
[Applaudissements]
mais pourquoi ne pas avoir interrompu la
partie je pense effectivement que
c'était la meilleure solution mais j'ai
eu peur si j'arrive à le match
d'aggraver la tension est même de mettre
en péril la sécurité des joueurs
en finale face à la tchécoslovaquie le
brésil tire la leçon de l'événement il
se montre étrangement prudent et
défensif
ce qui ne l empêche d'ailleurs pas de
gagner par trois buts à un
l'équipe de pelé remporté pour la
deuxième fois consécutive le trophée
rimet et sa sainteté a des cheveux noirs
épais de sang ce fut une sorte de
réédition de 1958 avec une équipe
presque identique mais plus expérimenté
et plus technique nous étions plus âgés
mais nous étions bien acquérir pour
remporter cette coupe tant convoitée par
le brésil
[Applaudissements]
la coupe 1966 se disputa à londres sous
le signe du boom télévisuelle plus de
500 millions de téléspectateurs avait à
présent la possibilité de suivre la
compétition
[Musique]
malheureusement le spectacle fut surtout
celui d'une extrême violence
au point que pelé menaçait de boycotter
la coupe
il faut convenir que dans le match
opposant son équipe à celle du portugal
il avait été l'objet de deux véritables
agressions
[Applaudissements]
commentaire de la vedette brésilienne le
football est pourri par la violence et
je n'ai pas l'intention de finir
invalides
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les arbitres vivait des moments
difficiles face notamment à des
argentins particulièrement déchaîné
heureusement la finale va s'avérer d'une
qualité exemplaire
elle oppose l'angleterre à l'allemagne
qui ouvre la marque
[Applaudissements]
mais l'angleterre et delhaize
en seconde mi temps les anglais
réussissent même à prendre l'aventage
[Applaudissements]
mais dans les dernières secondes
les allemands reviennent à la marque il
faut jouer les prolongations
aujourd'hui encore personne n'ose
affirmer formellement que le troisième
but anglais était valable
larbitre suisse décida de le valider
mais la balle at elle vraiment franchi
la ligne
ce but libérateur était en tout cas le
troisième marqué d'affilée par le
britannique joe afp un nouveau record à
inscrire sur les tablettes de la coupe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la reine élisabeth remise elle même le
trophée aux héros du jour et à leurs
managers
alf ramsey qui avait juré de conduire
16ème à la victoire
paris deux nuls
c'est dans un pays en pleine
effervescence politique que s'ouvrit la
coupe du monde 1970 version mexicaine
[Musique]
on ne déplore heureusement aucun
incident grave et à vrai dire ce qui
préoccupait avant tout les joueurs
c'était la chaleur et l'altitude
les brésiliens partie d'une nouvelle
fois favori et sérieux candidat à une
troisième victoire mais les anglais
entendent défendre chèrement leurs
titres et les annonces se sentait
pousser des ailes fort de leur étoile
montante un certain franz beckenbauer
[Applaudissements]
on jouait le grand jeu contre l'italie
ils nous ont battus 4 à 3 ils sont
passés au final un match homérique
[Musique]
pris comme cible fauché plusieurs
reprises beckenbauer fit preuve d'un
courage et d'une détermination farouche
l'allemagne perd 10 le match mais c'est
ce jour là sans doute que kaiser franz
forget à sa réputation
ce match je ne les oublierai jamais en
finale c'est le brésil qui affronte
l'italie
[Musique]
pelé qui participe pour la troisième
fois la compétition marque le premier
but de la tête
les sud américains sont littéralement
aux anges
[Musique]
en seconde mi temps il s'impose à leurs
adversaires dans tous les compartiments
de jeu
les européens inventeurs du football
sont dépassés par leurs élèves les plus
doués
de ce jour pelé fut et reste le plus
grand joueur au monde
[Musique]
remportant le trophée pour la troisième
fois le brésil conquis le droit de le
conserver
[Musique]
au lendemain de cette coupe mexicaine
pelé fut accueilli en france comme le
premier ambassadeur du football mondial
l'année suivante il se retira de
l'équipe nationale brésilienne
mais sa retraite fut de courte durée en
1974 le cosmos de new york lui propose
un contrat de trois ans d'un montant
fabuleux pour l'époque
quatre millions et demi de dollars
[Musique]
technicien hors pair mais aussi
personnalité ouverte et chaleureuse
pelé conquis les américains et il fit
beaucoup pour le développement du
football aux états unis
[Musique]
70000 spectateurs étaient présents pour
assister au match d'adieu du roi pelé
parmi eux assis aux côtés du père du
peuple et mohamed ali
[Applaudissements]
le président carter avait délégué son
fils bobby moore et bien d'autres
joueurs vedettes avaient fait le
déplacement pour honorer cette carrière
exemplaire et applaudir le dernier
message de pelé à ses supporters
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la sanguine époque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
la coupe du monde de football reste de
tous les trophées sportifs le plus
convoité
[Musique]
en 1994 le titre se dispute pour la
première fois aux états unis 51 matchs
joués en oeuvre des principales villes
du pays
la finale se déroulant au pasadena rose
bowl de los angeles
[Musique]
une aventure dont les origines remontent
à 1930 avec l'organisation en uruguay de
la première version de la coupe
une aventure qui durant plus de quarante
ans a ensuite tenu en haleine des
centaines de millions de supporters
grâce notamment à l'immense audiences
supplémentaires apportés par la
télévision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'allemande de l'ouest fait choisi pour
organiser les épreuves en 1974 et elle
ne lésine pas sur les moyens
jamais on n'avait vu de cérémonie
d'ouverture aussi spectaculaire
on inaugurait aussi un tout nouveau
trophée ce fut là naît d'une
confirmation celle de l'allemand franz
beckenbauer et d'une révélation celle du
néerlandais johan cruyff
capitaines des deux équipes les plus
dynamiques de la compétition ces deux
vedettes avait toutes les chances de se
retrouver face à face en finale et c'est
effectivement ce qui arriva on notera
pour l'anecdote que la partie failli
débuté sans piquer le corner coupable
distraction d'un officiel surmené
on n'avait rien perdu pour attendre ce
fut un match de rêve l'art
footballistiques à l'état pur offert par
la télévision après 2,1 milliards de
téléspectateurs
après seulement une minute de jeu cruyff
est victime d'une faute dans la surface
adverse
[Applaudissements]
les hollandais mark penalty
peu après le scénario se reproduit mais
dans l'autre camp
[Applaudissements]
penalty réussi égalité des deux équipes
quelques limites encore et l'allemand
gerd muller fait la différence
l'allemagne de l'ouest remporté la coupe
pour la deuxième fois
[Applaudissements]
la fifa pousse un soupir de soulagement
les temps étaient au terrorisme et les
organisateurs avaient reçu de nombreuses
menaces d'attentats heureusement aucune
ne fut mise à exécution
[Musique]
1978 la compétition repassa d'atlantique
destination l'argentine le pays était
alors dirigé par une junte militaire
ce qui offrit aux caméras quelques
images insolites comme celle de cet
amiral galonnés supervisant la qualité
des produits dérivés
[Musique]
toute l'organisation fut d'ailleurs
rondement menée avec une précision ne
laissant rien au hasard
pendant ce temps à des milliers de
kilomètres la hollande fait une victoire
de qualification contre la belgique
un succès qui lui ouvrait in extremis
les portes de l'argentine
restez cependant une grande inconnue
crif serait-il ou non de la partie tous
troublion pour aux adversaires de
l'équipe de holland crif la cible cruyff
inlassablement faucher et une fois
encore dans ce dernier match contre la
belgique qui allait peser lourd dans
cette décision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
y aurait-il en argentine que ferez vous
cet été peut-être regarder la télévision
mais en tout cas
j'arrête le football en argentine
le manager de l'équipe nationale c'est
un luis menotti était à la recherche de
la formation idéale
baptisé l'artiste en raison de ses goûts
vestimentaires mais aussi intellectuelle
menotti s'était donné pour mission une
tâche quasiment impossible
transformer une bonne dizaine de joueurs
argentins farouchement individualiste en
une équipe cohérente
parmi eux osvaldo ardiles est celui là
même qui dirige aujourd'hui la célèbre
équipe londonienne de tottenham hotspurs
son opinion sur les nantis c'est le
meilleur entraîneur que j'ai jamais
connu
il m'a beaucoup marqué il avait l'art de
vous mettre en confiance
il vous répéter sans cesse que vous
étiez le meilleur vous finissiez par le
croire mais revenons à cette fameuse
coupe 1978
grâce à la télévision ils seront
dorénavant plus d'un milliard de
téléspectateurs à pouvoir suivre le
spectacle 1 milliard à pouvoir admirer
le français bernard lacombe
lorsqu'il marque 38 secondes après le
coup d'envoi le but est plus rapide de
la tête
1 milliard à suivre le naufrage de
l'équipe décosse d'anima claude devant
les péruviens pratiquement inconnu après
avoir battu les écossais 3 à 1
les péruviens réussi un nul 0 0 face aux
hollandais et il balaie hier les
iraniens pour accéder au deuxième tour
2e tour au cours duquel s'affrontèrent
sans se départager les adversaires de la
finale de 74 la hollande et l'allemagne
de l'ouest peut conserver leurs chances
les allemands devaient dominer
confortablement l'autriche tout au
contraire ils furent battus 3 buts à 2
[Applaudissements]
le dimanche 25 juin 1978 77 mille
spectateurs s'entassent dans le stade
river plate de bruyne aux crs pour
assister au match décisif
[Musique]
l'argentine et la hollande paraissent de
niveau égal difficiles à départager
[Musique]
37e minute de jeu hardy laisse pas sale
hockey qui passa kempès qui marque
à la reprise le score est toujours de 1
à 0 les argentins pas restent nerveux
ils ont raison à la 81e minute van de
kerkhof passe à bordeaux 8 qui marque de
la tête
[Musique]
on joue les prolongations à la 103e
minute kempès surnommé le matador se
joue des défenseurs hollandais et donne
l'avancé à son équipe
à la 114e minute enfin c'est l'estocade
bertoni marque trois papas
l'émotion est indescriptible dans le
camp de l'argentine qui rejoint ainsi le
club très fermé des vainqueurs de la
coupe
elle en devient le sixième membre
buenos aires svq ce dimanche là une nuit
de folie
je n'ai pas le détail c'était vraiment
la fête
l'argentine était en délire je ne
pouvais me rendre nulle part sans être
étouffée par une foule de supporters
tout le monde reconnaissait voulu
m'accompagner
c'était à la fois infernal fou et
merveilleux cette victoire suscita et
confirma en argentine bien des vocations
comme celle d'un certain diego maradona
[Musique]
il révèle assez extraordinaire talent à
l'occasion d'une tournée de trois
matches effectués au japon avec son
équipe des boca juniors il fallait toute
la précision du ralenti pour percevoir
la qualité exceptionnelle de sa
technique y ajoutant capacité
d'accélération et endurance il
réunissait toutes les qualités
susceptibles d'en faire un second pelé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce talent hors du commun valu à maradona
les plus hautes récompenses sportives
ainsi ce ballon d'or récompensant le
joueur désigné comme le meilleur de la
coupe du monde disputée au mexique
mais la médaille a son revers
[Musique]
le champion suivi l'énorme pression déjà
lorsqu'il jouait à naples
à la fin des années 80 aucune retraite
si secrète soit elles n'échappent et à
la persévérance de ces femmes la
sélection de l'argentine pour la coupe
94 donnera au public l'occasion de
s'enflammer pour lui puis une nouvelle
fois en 1982 la tradition ramener la
coupe en europe plus précisément à
barcelone où maradona joue alors
moyennant un contrat de près de deux
millions de dollars
[Applaudissements]
mélodie qui avaient cessé de fumer
rallumant une cigarette lorsque
l'argentine fut battu 1 à 0 par la
belgique est une autre lorsqu elle
s'incline à 3 0 face au brésil après que
maradona était expulsé
[Applaudissements]
contestant un but que lui avait infligée
l'équipe de france le koweit menace à le
quitter la compétition
son prince héritier qui s'efforçait de
calmer les esprits écopa d'une amende de
8000 dollars il en avait les moyens
malgré la présence du roi d'espagne de
quelques éminences et de près de cent
mille autres spectateurs la finale entre
l'italie et l'allemagne de l'ouest se
traîne sur un combiné au peu de tirs au
but et beaucoup de coups bas mais à la
56e minute
rossi marque pour l'italie brusquement
réveillé les italiens double le score
avec tardelli et dans la foulée il de
triple avec conti malgré un tardif
sursaut allemands les italiens
l'emportent 3 ha et deviennent champions
pour la troisième fois en 1986 la coupe
se disputera dans un mexique dévasté
quelques mois plus tôt par un terrible
tremblement de terre
[Musique]
le coup d'envoi fut néanmoins donné
comme prévu le 31 mai au 1er tour contre
la belgique le mexique ouvre la marque
pour fêter l'événement sanchez envoie la
balle dans les gradins et écope d'un
carton jaune qui ne l'empêchent pas
aussi doit près d'alourdir le score
résultat final belgique un mexique 2 est
un pays en délire
en quarts de finale l'argentine affronte
l'angleterre au début de la seconde mi
temps
maradona marque l'un des buts qui a fait
couler le plus d'encre
un but de la main les anglais le pense
et beaucoup d'autres avec eux mais pas
larbitre kino valide sur ce mardi la
double la marque sans contestation
possible linker réduit le score mais il
est trop tard les anglais sont éliminés
cette coupe 1986 fit cependant de
lineker une superstar titulaire du titre
du meilleur buteur avec 6 buts
[Musique]
encore un surdoué un virtuose du jeu
collectif mais qui sait aussi prendre
ses responsabilités dans les situations
les plus problématiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lineker est aussi un joueur d'une
correction exemplaire
jamais dans toute sa carrière
professionnelle
exclu du terrain
[Musique]
ce mélange de rigueur et de spontanéité
en fait un des meilleurs joueurs du
monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais revenons au mexique et à la finale
qui oppose l'argentine et l'allemagne
un match passionnant l'argentine ouvre
le score sur coup franc et double la
marque en début de deuxième mi-temps les
hameaux réplique sèchement sur corner
avec roumanie gueule et toujours sur
corner avec voleurs
à 9 minutes du terme sur passe de
maradona burruchaga déboule et
l'argentine l'emporter 3 à 2 c'est sa
deuxième victoire en huit ans
[Musique]
on connaissait déjà le lieu de la
prochaine compétition l'italie restait à
accomplir une épreuve préliminaire
le tirage au sort il eu lieu en décembre
1987 à zurich en présence de pelé invité
d'honneur l'italie pays d'accueil et
l'argentine derniers vainqueurs étaient
dispensés des épreuves de qualification
demeure est en cours ce sont douze
équipes nationales lancées pour près de
deux ans dans une éprouvante course
poursuite
[Musique]
parmi les favoris l'allemagne de l'ouest
à cologne token bauer avait à présent
troqué son maillot de joueur contre un
blouson d'entraîneur les sélectionnés de
l'équipe allemande ne pouvait que
beaucoup transpiré sous l'autorité d'un
tel patron un maître de jeu idéal pour
une formation d'élite
[Musique]
je suis un joueur international plus de
100 matches à mon actif je pense donc
que je maîtrise bien la matière si le
transmettra ces jeunes d'armes et des
épaules mandante un redoutable cogneur
jürgen klinsmann
et un excellent gardien de but bodo bing
dans leur dernier match de qualification
les allemands l'emportèrent sur le pays
de galles le magicien beckenbauer
n'avait à l'évidence rien perdu de ses
talents angleterre novembre 89 sur le
terrain d'entraînement de gay cham
abeilles bobby robson un vétéran
d'incorporation des entraîneurs
nationaux étaient fiers d'avoir qualifié
son équipe sans concéder un seul but
il portait une attention particulière à
la forme physique de ses poulains d'où
ce test qui devait lui permettre de
déceler tout déséquilibre entre la jambe
gauche et la jambe droite des joueurs
cet équilibre est essentielle l'agent de
pied gauche a exactement au même niveau
que le jambes et pieds droits des
recettes inédites pour un nouveau défi
un incident spectaculaire marqué le
match de qualification brésil chili
le gardien chilien roja ce prétendu
avoir été blessé par le jet d'un
projectiles enflammés sept coéquipiers
saisir ce prétexte pour quitter le
terrain en race pure a dit m
dispensé des matches de qualification
les italiens avaient également
l'avantagé de connaître le style de
beaucoup de leurs futurs adversaires par
ailleurs sous contrat dans des clubs
locaux
[Musique]
en phase éliminatoire les etats-unis se
retrouvèrent quant à eux face à trinidad
un challenger apparemment bien modeste
mais qui va user de trésors de malice
[Musique]
prudents les américains s'étaient
longuement et chauffer leur entraîneur
bob gagnent leur avait tout prévu
tous sauf l'étrange carnaval mise en
scène par les supporters du cru
ça c'est comme on l'a décrite c'était
une sorte de marie rouge
nous avions dit le joueur en garde nous
les avions prévenu que le public de
trinidad était extrêmement confiante je
ne savais pas grand chose de leur
capacité
[Musique]
mais il n'y avait pas de doute on sait
frénésie ambiante ne pouvait faire que
monter la pression parmi les joueurs
[Musique]
nous avons eu l'initiative dans tous les
secteurs à la fois défensifs et
offensifs afin de neutraliser
l'affluence de cette foule je pense que
notre équipe y est parvenu
c'est la stupéfaction lorsque
l'américain paul gallagher et marque le
seul but du match
[Applaudissements]
battre trinidad à trinidad et était
rouge le stade les spectateurs pas de
supporters américains et nous avons
réussi ce but rapide c'est notre
football dans le xxème siècle pour la
première fois les états unis accéder à
la phase finale de la coupe
la coupe 1990 s'ouvrait en italie sur
une double surprise
une inauguration en forme de défilé de
mode et la révélation d'une star le
camerounais roger milla
grâce à lui un petit pays d'afrique
réalisé la performance d'accéder aux
quarts de finale face à l'angleterre
le sorcier était formel 2 1 pour le
cameroun évidemment hélas à pas mal de
dents c'est être en paix les esprits
étaient avec lineker sur penalty et
l'angleterre l'emporta mais de justesse
par trois buts à deux autres nouveaux
promus en quarts de finale la république
d'irlande
soutenez pas de supporters enthousiastes
je vais dire à mon patron qui paie mon
congé l'habitacle et que je fais
beaucoup mieux l'artisan de ce succès
était entraîneur jack charlton
difficile pour un ancien joueur
britannique de se faire accepter en
irlande
tous ont peu réagi
les irlandais sont enthousiastes chaque
match nous faisons le plein figurer
parmi les huit meilleures équipes du
monde
beaucoup s'en contenteraient moins
exaltantes des scènes comme celle ci
carton rouge de l'allemand voleur qui a
commis une faute et hollandais riesch
garde qui lui a craché au visage
le stade est en ébullition commentaires
de jürgen klinsmann
[Applaudissements]
cela traîne à la pression de la foule à
l'importance de l'enjeu
pendant quelques secondes on perd le
contrôle de soi
ils se sont excusés c'est tout ce qu'il
pouvait faire
klinsmann lui a gardé tout son sang
froid
son but écarte la hollande de la finale
[Applaudissements]
les italiens se découvre une nouvelle
vedette salvatore schillaci un sicilien
avec six buts à son actif il sera sacré
meilleur buteur de la compétition
une femme se fait en perspective pour le
retour à l'herbe de l'enfant du pays
[Applaudissements]
et voici l'un des héros de cette coupe
le gardien sergio goycochea grâce à lui
l'argentine remporté la demi-finale qui
me posent à l'italie et qui se joue
malheureusement au tir au plus tôt
la ont joué en coupe du monde
c'est notre ambition à tous je me sens
privilégié d'avoir permis au pays
d'accéder à la finale
dans cette finale se retrouvent face à
face les mêmes protagonistes que quatre
ans plus tôt au mexique l'allemagne de
l'ouest et l'argentine
cette fois cependant ce sont les
allemands qui sont favoris conséquence
les argentins pratiquent un football
heurter et violent klinsmann est leur
première victime
[Applaudissements]
justement sanctionné les italiens voient
leurs tactiques se retourner contre eux
voleur est bousculé dans la surface de
réparation et bremer se retrouve seul
face à gautschi à
[Applaudissements]
ce sera le seul but de la partie
l'allemagne remporté la coupe pour la
troisième fois sur le moment on est tout
simplement heureux mais heureux surtout
parce que c'est fini après deux mois
pendant lesquels chaque jour on n'a
pensé qu'à cela
on est mentalement épuisé
et pourtant la coupe du monde cela reste
tout de même amusant à jamais la wii
j'ai fait la fête trois ou quatre jours
sans dormir c'était bien
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
2e match
[Applaudissements]
il dure cependant s'incliner sous le
pression sud américaine
le meilleur buteur l'argentin stabile la
finale oppose l'argentine à l'uruguay
c'est un joueur manchots castro qui
marque le but décisif faisant de
l'uruguay le premier champion du monde
de football
[Applaudissements]
en 1934 mussolini accueilli
personnellement les 32 délégations qui
allait participer à rome à la deuxième
édition de la coupe
il transforme à l'événement en opération
de relations publiques
d'autant que son pays accède à la finale
le manager italien vittorio pozzo
galvani son équipe est la condition de
la victoire
[Applaudissements]
les italiens sont opposés la
tchécoslovaquie dont les supporters
n'ont pas eu une grande distance à
parcourir pour venir soutenir leur
équipe en masse mais aussi en vain car
l'équipe d'italie remporté par 2 buts à
[Applaudissements]
la fifa a exprimé des réserves sur la
récupération de la compétition tant les
pouvoir fasciste
il n'empêche les preuves suscita un
énorme engouement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la coupe du monde 1938 je dispute à à
paris les français investir 2 millions
de francs dans son organisation
du jamais vu à l'époque autre record
celui des but marqué au premier tour
le brésil s'impose de justesse contre la
pologne 6 bus 1,5
la finale se dispute entre l'équipe
d'italie toujours pilotée par pozzo et
celle de hongrie
les italiens gagnante avec mérite par 4
buts à 2 et remporte le trophée pour la
deuxième fois
[Applaudissements]
la compétition était en plein essor mais
cette euphorie se trouva rapidement mise
en veilleuse pendant une décennie le
monde allait se trouver mobilisés par
d'autres préoccupations
[Musique]
ce n'est que 12 ans plus tard en 1950
que loin de l'europe encore en ruine
fête organisée au brésil la quatrième
édition de la coupe l'équipe d'italie
héritière du titre s'échauffant sur le
bateau qui l'a conduit à rio
et
[Musique]
les brésiliens ont déménagé un stade
immense pouvant contenir plus deux cent
mille personnes et qui demeure l'un des
plus vastes du monde
[Musique]
regrettable péripéties les indiens se
retirèrent de la compétition entre eux
que la fifa ait prétendu leur imposer le
port des chaussures pour la première
fois les anglais accéder à la phase
finale
mais à la stupéfaction générale ils
furent battus 1 à 0 par les états unis
c'est devant une assistance record que
se disputent la finale entre le brésil
et l'uruguay
le brésil est favori il est battu par 2
buts à 1 des supporters pique des crises
d'hystérie
on parle de cas le suicide
mais nous sommes bas avaient été dédiés
à la victoire brésilienne
on n'entendait jamais la première note
un véritable enjeu de deuil pour le
football brésilien
je
[Musique]
en 1954 la compétition veut traverser
l'atlantique est la suisse qui
inaugurait surtout à l'europe mis les
petits plats dans les grands
elle fit frappé démenait pour marquer
l'événement une initiative originale en
matière de marketing
autres nouveautés promises à un bel
avenir
la retransmission télévisée des
compétitions
[Applaudissements]
ce fut aussi la grande année des buteurs
140 buts marqués en 26 matches
[Applaudissements]
par un dimanche pluvieux la star
ambroise puskas mène son équipe à
l'assaut de la finale qui l'opposé à
l'allemagne de l'ouest
malgré une blessure subie quelques jours
plus tôt puskas fait des merveilles
il marque à deux reprises au cours des
huit premières minutes
mais les allemands s'accroche
[Applaudissements]
il marque un premier but
puis un second
l'allemagne égalise
[Applaudissements]
et un troisième l'allemagne l'emporté 3
à 2 mais t'en fous une exceptionnelle
série hongroise de 30 matchs
internationaux sans défaite
[Applaudissements]
à l'occasion de la coupe du monde 1958
disputé en suède
les supporters du monde entier de
découvrir un jeune prodige brésilien
appelé pelé une époustouflante le dat
offensive pour une équipe au mieux de sa
forme
le brésil introduisit cette année là un
système de jeu qui allait faire fortune
le 4-2-4 quatre défenseurs deux milieux
de terrain quatre attaquants
[Musique]
jouant sur classement le brésil est
opposée en finale à la suède
c'est goliath contre david et pourtant
c'est david qui ouvre la marque
[Musique]
mais les sud américains prennent
rapidement le dessus pour l'emporter 5 à
[Musique]
en marquant le troisième de ses buts
pelé se hisse à 17 ans au rang de héros
national et devient grâce notamment à la
télévision la nouvelle coqueluche du
football mondial
[Applaudissements]
une des vedettes de cette équipe
brésilienne s'appelait mario zagallo il
avait remporté deux autres coupes du
monde en 1962 comme joueur et en 1970
comme manager mai 1958 demain pour lui
un souvenir exceptionnel descriptible
quand je repense agents de la chair de
poule
c'était tellement inattendu personne n'y
croyait
notre soulevé le brésil d'entousiasme et
notre retour au pays était inoubliable
nouveau jour
choisie pour organiser la coupe en 1962
au chili subi au cours des deux années
précédentes des tremblements de terre si
destructeur qui le monastère de
compromettre la compétition
les chiliens réussir cependant à relever
le défi et le magnifique stade de
santiago fut le théâtre de l'un des
matches les plus disputés de l'histoire
de la coupe il opposa le chili et
l'italie qui l'emporta de but à 0 et il
fut à ce point violent qu'on le baptisa
la bataille de santiago il fallut
beaucoup de diplomatie l arbitre anglais
ken ashton pour éviter qu'il se
transforme en pugilat collectif il a été
très difficile de remplir mon rôle
d'arbitré
ce match personne ne semblait souhaiter
qu'il est là tout le monde s'en sort
volontiers passée et notamment le fait
que le public sur le terrain avaient
réservé un très mauvais accueil à
l'équipe italienne
cela couvait d'ailleurs depuis plusieurs
jours
[Applaudissements]
mais pourquoi ne pas avoir interrompu la
partie je pense effectivement que
c'était la meilleure solution
j'ai eu peur si j'arrêtais le match
d'aggraver la tension est même de mettre
en péril la sécurité des joueurs
en finale face à la tchécoslovaquie le
brésil tire la leçon de l'événement il
se montre étrangement prudent et
défensif ce qui ne l'empêchent
d'ailleurs pas de gagner par trois buts
à un
l'équipe de pelé remporté pour la
deuxième fois consécutive le trophée
rimet et sa sainteté a des cheveux noirs
épais de sang ce fut une sorte de
réédition de 1958 avec une équipe
presque identique mais plus expérimenté
et plus technique nous étions plus âgés
mais nous étions bien acquérir pour
remporter cette coupe tant convoitée par
le brésil
[Applaudissements]
la coupe 1966 se dispute à londres sous
le signe du bund télévisuelle plus de
500 millions de téléspectateurs avait à
présent la possibilité de suivre la
compétition
malheureusement le spectacle fut surtout
celui d'une extrême violence
au point que pelé menacé de boycotter la
coupe
il faut convenir que dans le match
opposant son équipe à celle du portugal
il avait été l'objet de deux véritables
agressions
[Applaudissements]
commentaire de la vedette brésilienne le
football est pourri par la violence et
je n'ai pas l'intention de finir
invalides
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les arbitres vivent des moments
difficiles face notamment à des
argentins particulièrement déchaîné
heureusement la finale va s'avérer d'une
qualité exemplaire
elle oppose l'angleterre à l'allemagne
qui ouvre la marque
[Applaudissements]
mais l'angleterre et élèves
à
une seconde mi temps les anglais
réussissent même à prendre l'aventage
[Applaudissements]
mais dans les dernières secondes
les allemands reviennent à la marque il
faut jouer les prolongations
aujourd'hui encore personne n'ose
affirmer formellement que le troisième
but anglais était valable
l'art d'être suisse décida de le valider
mais la balle at elle vraiment franchi
la ligne
ce but libérateur était en tout cas le
troisième marqué d'affilée par le
britannique joe afp est un nouveau
record à inscrire sur les tablettes de
la coupe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la reine élisabeth remise elle même le
trophée aux héros du jour et à leurs
managers
alf ramsey qui avait juré de conduire
ses hommes à la victoire
paris deux nuls
c'est dans un pays en pleine
effervescence politique que s'ouvrit la
coupe du monde 1970 le version mexicaine
[Musique]
on ne déplore heureusement aucun
incident grave et à vrai dire ce qui
préoccupait avant tout les joueurs
c'était la chaleur et l'altitude
les brésiliens partagent une nouvelle
fois favori et sérieux candidat à une
troisième victoire mais les anglais
entendent défendre chèrement leurs
titres et les allemands se sentait
pousser des ailes forts de leur étoile
montante un certain franz beckenbauer
[Applaudissements]
nous allons jouer le grand jeu contre
l'italie 4 à 3 ils sont passés au final
un match homérique
[Musique]
pris comme cible fauché plusieurs
reprises beckenbauer fit preuve d'un
courage et d'une détermination farouche
l'allemagne perd 10 le match mais c'est
ce jour là sans doute que kaiser franz
forget à sa réputation
ce match je ne les oublierai jamais en
finale c'est le brésil qui affronte
l'italie
[Musique]
les qui participe pour la troisième fois
à la compétition marque le premier but
de la tête
les sud américains sont littéralement
aux anges
[Musique]
en seconde mi temps il s'impose à leurs
adversaires dans tous les compartiments
le jour
[Musique]
les européens inventeurs du football
sont dépassés par leurs élèves les plus
doués
lyon
de ce jour pelé fut et reste le plus
grand joueur au monde
[Musique]
remportant le trophée pour la troisième
fois le brésil conquis le droit de le
conserver
[Musique]
m
au lendemain de cette coupe mexicaine
pelé fut accueilli en france comme le
premier ambassadeur du football mondial
l'année suivante il se retira de
l'équipe nationale brésilienne
mais sa retraite fut de courte durée en
1974 le cosmos de new york lui propose
un contrat de trois ans d'un montant
fabuleux pour l'époque
quatre millions et demi de dollars
[Musique]
technicien hors pair mais aussi
personnalité ouverte et chaleureuse
pelé conquis les américains et il fit
beaucoup pour le développement du
football aux états unis
[Musique]
70000 spectateurs étaient présents pour
assister au match d'adieu du roi pelé
parmi eux assis aux côtés du père de
pelé mohamed ali le président carter
avait délégué son fils bobby moore et
bien d'autres joueurs vedettes avaient
fait le déplacement pour honorer cette
carrière exemplaire et applaudir le
dernier message de pelé à ses supporters
[Applaudissements]
la sens d'une époque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la coupe du monde de football reste de
tous les trophées sportifs le plus
convoité
[Musique]
en 1994 le titre se dispute pour la
première fois aux états unis 51 matchs
joués en oeuvre des principales villes
du pays
la finale se déroulant au pasadena rose
bowl de los angeles
une aventure dont les origines remontent
à 1930 avec l'organisation en uruguay de
la première version de la coupe
une aventure qui durant plus de quarante
ans a ensuite tenu en haleine des
centaines de millions de supporters
grâce notamment à l'immense audiences
supplémentaires apportés par la
télévision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'album de l'ouest fait choisi pour
organiser les épreuves en 1974 et elle
ne lésine pas sur les moyens
jamais on n'avait vu une cérémonie
d'ouverture aussi spectaculaire
on inaugurait aussi un tout nouveau
trophée ce fut là naît d'une
confirmation celle de l'allemand franz
beckenbauer et d'une révélation celle du
néerlandais johan cruyff
capitaines des deux équipes les plus
dynamiques de la compétition ces deux
vedettes avait toutes les chances de se
retrouver face à face en finale et c'est
effectivement ce qui arriva on notera
pour l'anecdote que la partie failli
débuté sans piquer le corner coupable
distraction d'un officiel surmené
on n'avait rien perdu pour attendre ce
fut un match de rêve l'art
footballistiques à l'état pur offert par
la télévision après 2,1 milliards de
téléspectateurs
après seulement une minute de jeu cruyff
est victime d'une faute dans la surface
adverse
[Applaudissements]
les hollandais mark penalty
peu après le scénario se reproduit mais
dans l'autre camp
[Applaudissements]
penalty réussi égalité des deux équipes
quelques lignes encore et l'allemand
gerd muller fait la différence
l'allemagne de l'ouest ont remporté la
coupe pour la deuxième fois
[Applaudissements]
la fifa pousse un soupir de soulagement
les temps étaient au terrorisme et les
organisateurs avaient reçu de nombreuses
menaces d'attentats heureusement aucune
ne fut mise à exécution
[Musique]
1978 la compétition repassa d'atlantique
destination l'argentine le pays était
alors dirigé par une junte militaire
ce qui offrit aux caméras quelques
images insolites comme celle de cet
amiral galonnés supervisant la qualité
des produits dérivés
[Musique]
toute l'organisation fut d'ailleurs
rondement menée avec une précision ne
laissant rien au hasard
pendant ce temps à des milliers de
kilomètres la hollande fait une victoire
de qualification contre la belgique
un succès qui lui ouvrait in extremis
les portes de l'argentine
restait cependant une grande inconnue
crif serait-il ou non de la partie
trop brouillons pour les adversaires de
l'équipe de holland crif la cible cruyff
inlassablement faucher et une fois
encore dans ce dernier match contre la
belgique qui allait peser lourd dans sa
décision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
y aurait-il en argentine que ferez vous
cet été peut-être regarder la télévision
mais en tout cas
j'arrête le football en argentine
le manager de l'équipe nationale c'est
un luis menotti était à la recherche de
la formation idéale
baptisé l'artiste en raison de ses goûts
vestimentaires mais aussi intellectuelle
menotti s'était donné pour mission une
tâche quasiment impossible
transformer une bonne dizaine de joueurs
argentins farouchement individualiste en
une équipe cohérente
parmi eux osvaldo ardiles est ce celui
là même qui dirige aujourd'hui la
célèbre équipe londonienne de tottenham
hotspurs c'est un l'opinion sur mais
nanti c'est le meilleur entraîneur que
j'ai jamais connu
il m'a beaucoup marqué l'art de vous
mettre en confiance et vous répéter sans
cesse que vous étiez le meilleur vous
finissiez par le croire mais revenons à
cette fameuse coupe 1978
grâce à la télévision ils seront
dorénavant plus d'un milliard de
téléspectateurs à pouvoir suivre le
spectacle 1 milliard à pouvoir admirer
le français bernard lacombe
lorsqu'il marque 38 secondes après le
coup d'envoi le but est plus rapide de
la coupe
1 milliard à suivre le naufrage de
l'équipe décosse davina claude devant
les péruviens pratiquement inconnu après
avoir battu les écossais 3 à 1
les péruviens réussi un nul 0 0 face aux
hollandais et il balaie hier les
iraniens pour accéder au deuxième tour
2e tour au cours duquel s'affrontèrent
sans se départager les adversaires de la
finale de 74 la hollande et l'allemagne
de l'ouest peut conserver leurs chances
les allemands devaient dominer
confortablement l'autriche tout au
contraire il faut battu 3 buts à dos
[Applaudissements]
le dimanche 25 juin 1978 77 mille
spectateurs s'entassent dans le stade
river plate de buenos aires est ce pour
assister au match décisif
[Musique]
l'argentine et la hollande paraissent de
niveau égal difficiles à départager
[Musique]
37e minute de jeu hardy l'espace à l'occ
et qui passa kempès qui marque
à la reprise le score est toujours de 1
à 0 les argentins par espère veut
ils ont raison à la 81e minute van de
kerkhof passe à bordeaux 8 qui marque de
la tête
[Musique]
on joue les prolongations à la 103e
minute kempès surnommé le matador se
joue des défenseurs hollandais et donne
l'avancé à son équipe
[Musique]
à la 114e minute enfin c'est l'estocade
bertoni mark iii papon
l'émotion est indescriptible dans le
camp de l'argentine qui rejoint ainsi le
club très fermé des vainqueurs de la
coupe
elle en devient le sixième membre
buenos aires svq ce dimanche là une nuit
de folie
c'était vraiment la fête
l'argentine était en délire je ne
pouvais me rendre nulle part sans être
étouffée par une foule de supporters
tout le monde reconnaissait vous les
accompagnez c'était à la fois infernal
fou et merveilleux cette victoire
suscita et confirma en argentine
bien des vocations comme celle d'un
certain diego maradona
[Musique]
il révèle assez extraordinaire talent à
l'occasion d'une tournée de trois
matches effectués au japon avec son
équipe des boca juniors il fallait toute
la précision du ralenti pour percevoir
la qualité exceptionnelle de sa
technique il ya joué tant capacité
d'accélération et endurance il
réunissait toutes les qualités
susceptibles d'en faire un second pelé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce talent hors du commun valu à maradona
les plus hautes récompenses sportives
ainsi ce ballon d'or récompensant le
joueur désigné comme les meilleurs de la
coupe du monde disputée au mexique
mais la médaille a son revers le
champion aux subi une énorme pression
déjà lorsqu'il jouait à naples à la fin
des années 80 aucune retraite si secrète
soit elles n'échappent et à la
persévérance de ces femmes
la sélection de l'argentine pour la
coupe 94 donnera au public l'occasion de
s'enflammer pour lui une nouvelle fois
en 1982 la tradition ramener la coupe en
or plus précisément à barcelone où
maradona joue alors moyennant un contrat
de près de deux millions de dollars
mélodie qui avaient cessé de fumer
alluma une cigarette lorsque l'argentine
fut battu 1 à 0 par la belgique est une
autre lorsqu elle s'incline à 3 0 face
au brésil après que maradona était
expulsé
contestant un but que lui avait infligée
l'équipe de france le koweit menaçait de
quitter la compétition
son prince héritier qui s'efforçait de
calmer les esprits écopa d'une amende de
8000 dollars il en avait les moyens
malgré la présence du roi d'espagne de
quelques éminences et de près de cent
mille autres spectateurs la finale entre
l'italie et l'allemagne de l'ouest se
traîne sur un ton mineur peu de tirs au
but et beaucoup de coups bas mais à la
56e minute
rossi marque pour l'italie brusquement
réveillé les italiens double le score
avec tardelli et dans la foulée il le
triple avec conti
malgré un tardif sursaut allemands les
italiens l'emportent 3 à 1 et deviennent
champions pour la troisième fois en 1986
la coupe se disputera dans un mexique
dévasté quelques mois plus tôt par un
terrible tremblement de terre
[Musique]
le coup d'envoi fut néanmoins donné
comme prévu le 31 mai
au premier tour contre la belgique le
mexique ouvre la marque pour fêter
l'événement sanchez envoie la balle dans
les gradins et écope d'un carton jaune
qui ne l'empêchent pas aussi doit près
d'alourdir le score
résultat final belgique un mexique 2 est
un pays en délire
en quarts de finale l'argentine affronte
l'angleterre au début de la seconde mi
temps
maradona marque l'un des buts qui a fait
couler le plus d'encre un but de la main
les anglais le pense et beaucoup
d'autres avec eux mais pas l' arbitre
qui le valide sur ce mardi gras double
la marque sans contestation possible les
nos coeurs réduit le score mais il est
trop tard les anglais sont éliminés
[Applaudissements]
cette coupe 1986 fit cependant de
lineker une superstar titulaire du titre
du meilleur buteur avec 6 buts
[Musique]
encore un surdoué un virtuose du jeu
collectif mais qui sait aussi prendre
ses responsabilités dans les situations
les plus problématiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lineker est aussi un joueur d'une
correction exemplaire
jamais dans toute sa carrière
professionnelle il a été exclu du
terrain
[Musique]
ce mélange de rigueur et de spontanéité
en fait un des meilleurs joueurs du
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais revenons au mexique et à la finale
qui oppose l'argentine et l'allemagne
un match passionnant l'argentine ouvre
le score sur coup franc et double la
marque en début de deuxième mi temps les
allemands réplique sèchement sur corner
avec rummenigge heures et toujours sur
corner avec voleurs
à 9 minutes du terme sur passe de
maradona burruchaga déboule et
l'argentine remporté 3 à 2 c'est sa
deuxième victoire en huit ans
[Musique]
on connaissait déjà le lieu de la
prochaine compétition l'italie restait à
accomplir une épreuve préliminaire
le tirage au sort il eu lieu en décembre
1987 à zurich en présence de pelé invité
d'honneur l'italie pays d'accueil et
l'argentine derniers vainqueurs étaient
dispensés des épreuves de qualification
demeurait dans course 112 équipes
nationales lancées pour près de deux ans
dans une éprouvante course poursuite
[Musique]
parmi les favoris l'allemagne de l'ouest
à cologne d'automne bauer avait à
présent troqué son maillot de joueur
contre un blouson d'entraîneur les
sélectionnés de l'équipe allemande ne
pouvait que beaucoup transpiré sous
l'autorité d'un talent patron un maître
de jeu idéal pour une formation d'élite
[Musique]
je suis un joueur international
un peu de sang match à mon actif je
pense donc que je maîtrise bien la
matière si le transmettre à ces jeunes
25 années d'expérience d'armes et des
épaules montante un redoutable cogneur
jürgen klinsmann
et un excellent gardien de but boeing
dans leur dernier match des
qualifications les allemands
l'emportèrent sur le pays de galles le
magicien beckenbauer navette à
l'évidence rien perdu de ses talents
angleterre novembre 89 sur le terrain
d'entraînement de pêche à la bei bobby
robson un vétéran dans la corporation
des entraîneurs nationaux étaient fiers
d'avoir qualifié son équipe sans
concéder un seul but
il porte une attention particulière à la
forme physique de ses poulains d'où ce
test qui devait lui permettre de déceler
tout déséquilibre entre la jambe gauche
et la jambe droite des joueurs cet
équilibre est essentiel d'argent de pied
gauche
exactement au même niveau que jambes et
pieds droits des recettes inédites pour
un nouveau défi
un incident spectaculaire marqué le
match de qualification brésil et chili
le gardien chilien roja ce prétendu
avoir été blessé par le jet d'un
projectiles enflammés sept coéquipiers
saisir ce prétexte pour quitter le
terrain après enquête
en race pure a dit m
dispensé des matches de qualification
les italiens avaient également
l'avantagé de connaître le style de
beaucoup de leurs futurs adversaires par
ailleurs sous contrat dans des clubs
locaux
[Musique]
en phase éliminatoire les etats-unis se
retrouvèrent quant à eux face à trinidad
un challenger apparemment bien modeste
mais qui va user de trésors de malice
[Musique]
prudents les américains s'étaient
longuement et chauffer leur entraîneur
bob gensler avait tout prévu
tous sauf l'étrange carnaval mise en
scène par les supporters du cru
oui ça c'est comment la décrypter
c'était une sorte de marée rouge
nous avions nos joueurs en garde nous
les avions prévenu que le public de
trinidad était extrêmement confiante je
ne savais pas grand chose de leur
capacité mais il n'y avait pas de doute
on sait frénésie ambiante ne pouvait
faire que monter la pression parmi les
joueurs
[Musique]
nous avons eu l'initiative dans tous les
secteurs à la fois défensifs et
offensifs afin de neutraliser
l'affluence de cette foule
je pense que notre équipe qui est
parvenue
c'est la stupéfaction lorsque
l'américain paul galerie marque le seul
but du match
nous devons battre trinidad à trinidad
tt rouge le stade les spectateurs pas de
supporters américains et nous avons
réussi ce but
pulsé notre football dans le xxème
siècle pour la première fois les états
unis accéder à la phase finale de la
coupe
la coupe 1990 s'ouvrait en italie sur
une double surprise
une inauguration en forme de défilé de
mode et la révélation d'une star le
camerounais roger milla
grâce à lui un petit pays d'afrique
réalisé la performance d'accéder aux
quarts de finale face à l'angleterre
le sorcier était formel 2 1 pour le
cameroun évidemment hélas à pas mal de
dents c'est être en paix
les esprits étaient avec les nightcup's
sur penalty et l'angleterre l'emporta
mais de justesse par 3 buts à 2
[Applaudissements]
autre nouveau promu en quarts de finale
la république d'irlande
soutenu par des supporters enthousiastes
je veux dire à mon patron qui pme congés
on m'a dit que je vais beaucoup mieux
l'artisan de ce succès et thank you know
jack charlton difficile pour un ancien
joueur britannique de se faire accepter
en irlande tout ce que réagir et les
irlandais sont enthousiastes à chaque
match nous faisons le plein figurer
parmi les huit meilleures équipes du
monde
beaucoup s'en contenteraient moins
exaltantes des scènes comme celle ci
carton rouge l'allemand voleur qui a
commis une faute et hollandais riesch
garde qui lui a craché au visage
le stade est en ébullition commentaire
de yogen klinsmann cela tient à la
pression de la foule à l'importance de
l'enjeu
pendant quelques secondes on perd le
contrôle de soi
ils se sont excusés c'est tout ce qu'il
pouvait faire
klinsmann lui a gardé tout son sang
froid
son but écarte la hollande de la finale
[Applaudissements]
les italiens se découvre une nouvelle
vedette salvatore schillaci un sicilien
avec six buts à son actif il sera sacré
meilleur buteur de la compétition
une femme se fait en perspective pour le
retour à palerme de l'enfant du pays
[Applaudissements]
et voici l'un des héros de cette coupe
le gardien sergio goycochea grâce à lui
l'argentine remporté la demi finale qui
l'opposé à l'italie et qui se joue
malheureusement aux tirs au but
[Applaudissements]
l'homme a également joué en coupe du
monde
c'est notre ambition à tous je me sens
privilégié d'avoir permis au pays
d'accéder à la finale
dans cette finale se retrouvent face à
face les mêmes protagonistes que quatre
ans plus tôt mexique l'allemagne de
l'ouest et l'argentine
cette fois cependant ce sont les
allemands qui sont favoris conséquence
les argentins pratiquent un football
heurter et violent klinsmann est leur
première victime
[Applaudissements]
justement sanctionné les italiens voient
leurs tactiques se retourner contre eux
voleur est bousculé dans la surface de
réparation et bremer se retrouve seul
face à google chez à
[Applaudissements]
ce sera le seul but de la partie
l'allemagne remporté la coupe pour la
troisième fois tout simplement heureux
mais heureux surtout parce que c'est
fini après deux mois pendant lesquels
chaque jour n'a pensé qu'à cela
on est mentalement épuisé
et pourtant la coupe du monde cela reste
tout de même amusant
ah oui j'ai fait la fête trois ou quatre
jours sans dormir c'était bien